[Aplausos]
[Música]
a broches los cinturones porque estamos
en mitad de la mayor crisis energética
de los últimos 50 años pero todo eso ya
lo sabéis todo el mundo está pagando
auténticas fortunas para tener
electricidad y gas en su casa y en
algunos países el precio del gas se ha
llegado a triplicar pero ojo porque eso
no es lo peor si veis este vídeo desde
centroeuropa en países como alemania o
república checa vuestra mayor pesadilla
no es que suban el precio del gas aún
más eso ya lo dais por descontado
vuestro mayor miedo será que simple y
llanamente no tengáis con que calentar
vuestra casa de este invierno para que
os hagáis una idea en el momento en el
que hacemos este vídeo los alemanes se
están apresurando a comprar calefactores
eléctricos de hecho amazon.de es decir
el amazon alemán ya está dando listas de
espera de meses para enviar radiadores
eléctricos habéis oído bien los
radiadores en el año 2022 sean el
equivalente a lo que en el año 2020 fue
el papel higiénico y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando muchos esto no es nada
nuevo a ver en otoño del año 2021
también hablábamos de toda una crisis
mundial del gas natural los precios
también se habían disparado en aquel
momento se juntaron dos fenómenos
años de desinversión en combustibles
fósiles y una subida repentina de la
demanda del gas conclusión precios por
las nubes pero este año es distinto esta
vez tenemos que añadir la guerra de
ucrania y las sanciones a rusia dicho de
otra forma que el escenario actual se
resume en una frase sálvese quien pueda
al final del vídeo entenderéis los tres
escenarios más probables donde nos
podemos ver abocados todos los europeos
y si el último es realmente preocupante
pero ojo porque todavía habrá alguno que
diga bueno a mí qué más me da yo no vivo
en europa que me importa todo esto pues
más te vale preocuparte querido amigo o
amiga porque esta crisis es mundial y de
hecho ya está afectando a países tan
remotos como pakistán estamos a punto de
entrar en uno de los inviernos más
inciertos que hemos vivido la crisis del
gas puede tener consecuencias de todo
tipo consecuencias tan disparatadas como
esta crisis de la cerveza las cervezas
checas podrían verse ahogadas por la
escasez de gas los que conozcáis bien
república checa ya sabéis que en este
país sin cerveza se puede armar
cualquier tipo de revolución así que la
pregunta que hoy nos hacemos es de
verdad puede europa quedar sin gas
natural este invierno como afecta a todo
esto a otros países del mundo cuáles son
los números exactos de esta crisis y que
puede hacer el viejo continente para
evitar una apocalipsis hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
quiero haceros un anuncio muy especial
estamos en un año de mundial de fútbol y
tenemos una sorpresa que os va a
encantar la liga visual política habéis
oído
[Aplausos]
de la mano de nuestros amigos de mi
wenger hemos puesto en marcha una liga
fantasy donde podremos competir entre
todos participar en la liga visual
política es algo muy sencillo y por
supuesto totalmente gratuito y además
podréis conseguir un montón de premios
simplemente tenéis que seguir el enlace
que os dejamos aquí abajo en los
comentarios o en la descripción de este
vídeo y una vez os descarguéis la app de
biden gere si es que no la tenéis ya os
llevará directamente a nuestra liga
entonces tan sólo tendréis que asignar
un nombre de vuestro equipo y listo ya
estaréis preparados para gestionar
vuestro propio equipo y enfrentaros a
couto alberto y am y empezaréis con un
equipo aleatorio y un presupuesto con el
que podréis convertiros en una especie
de florentino y fichar a vuestras
mejores apuestas por ejemplo eres de los
que creen en luego barça de laporta y
piensas que lewandowski dembélé y pedri
se van a salir qué crees que modric o
benzema van a seguir al máximo nivel
pues ya sabes por supuesto también
podrás vender jugadores para hacer caja
porque y esto es lo más importante
siempre siempre siempre tendrás que
tener las cuentas en positivo para poder
puntuar eres el manager y tienes que
demostrar que sabes lo que estás
haciendo la pregunta es crees que podrás
derrotar el equipo de visual polític
pues apuntados en la liga de visual
política en mi wenger y preparados para
competir y ahora sí vamos a ver un poco
de historia
y
puede cortar el gas rusia
puede rusia cortar todo el gas que
suministra europa la respuesta a esta
pregunta es que no pero es decir es casi
impensable que rusia llegue a cortar el
suministro de gas al 100% sin embargo
hay un pero gigantesco para empezar
vamos a hacernos otra pregunta muy
importante para qué sirve el gas natural
exactamente pues bien el gas natural
sirve para tres grandes propósitos
generar energía eléctrica genera el
calor para ciertas industrias y
alimentar las calefacciones de los
hogares
para que os hagáis una idea el gas
supone alrededor del 21 por ciento del
mix energético de toda la unión europea
sin embargo no todos los países tienen
el mismo mix energético por ejemplo en
finlandia el gas supone únicamente un 7
por ciento del mix el resto de la
energía viene de fuentes renovables y
reactores nucleares en países como
polonia o república checa- hablamos del
17 por ciento chequia tiene energía
nuclear y polonia tiene carbón sin
embargo en alemania se acercan al 26 por
ciento
[Música]
os preguntaréis pero por qué pues porque
en alemania tuvieron la feliz idea de
cerrar todos sus reactores nucleares y
reducir a la vez el consumo de carbón
como os podéis imaginar el vacío que han
ido dejando estas fuentes de energía se
ha llenado por supuesto con renovables
pero también con gas natural pero espera
un momento porque esto es solo parte del
problema
[Música]
porque al margen del mix energético de
cada país hay algo donde el gas natural
es totalmente insustituible por ejemplo
los altos hornos de las fábricas
siderúrgicas solo se pueden defender con
gas natural hay un montón de industrias
que funcionan únicamente con gas natural
y no sólo eso el 40 por ciento de las
calefacciones de toda europa funcionan a
base de gas natural es decir que por
muchas fuentes de energía alternativas
que queramos utilizar el gas es
imprescindible para tener calor en casa
este invierno y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando algunos sobre todo los que
veáis este vídeo desde países cálidos de
latinoamérica por ejemplo venga ya pues
tampoco es tanto problema los europeos
os ponéis una mantita este invierno y
problema resuelto nunca habéis pasado el
invierno en república checa es fácil
llegar a los 15 grados bajo cero es
decir que no es ninguna broma pasar un
invierno sin calefacción es simplemente
inimaginable y a no ser que hayáis
vivido en una cueva durante todo este
año 2022 ya sabéis que la mayoría del
gas que consumimos en europa viene de la
madre rusia atentos a este mapa
en general el gas ruso supone el 40 por
ciento de todo el gas que se consume en
europa hay países por supuesto con menos
dependencia por ejemplo los españoles o
los italianos pagarán el gas mucho más
caro este invierno pero tendrán gas
porque pues porque prácticamente nada
viene de rusia sin embargo hay países
donde casi el 100% del gas les viene de
la madre rusia pero de todos los países
con problemas alemania se lleva la palma
no solo son especialmente dependientes
del gas además dependen demasiado del
gas ruso también me gustaría hacer una
mención especial a polonia si polonia es
uno de los pocos países que realmente se
tomó en serio el problema de la
dependencia del gas ruso y por eso
construyeron un gasoducto con noruega
antes de que fuera demasiado tarde
gasoducto que fue terminado este verano
gracias a eso ahora están bastante mejor
preparados para lidiar con esta crisis
pero de eso hablaremos más tarde
[Música]
lo cierto es que si putin corta algas
alemania y muchos otros países tienen un
problema la pregunta es de verdad le
interesa hacerlo la respuesta es que en
principio no para que os hagáis una idea
las exportaciones energéticas suponen
más del 60% de todos los ingresos del
gobierno
así que jugar con el suministro puede
ser algo muy peligroso para la propia
supervivencia del gobierno ruso cerrar
el grifo del gas a los precios actuales
le costaría a rusia decenas de miles de
millones de dólares al tiempo que
también aceleraría los planes de los
países afectados para poner fin a
cualquier suministro importante que
provenga de este país
y europa es con diferencia su mejor
cliente no sólo eso rusia no puede
cambiar de clientes de la noche a la
mañana todos esos campos de gas están
conectados por gasoductos con europa y
no hay tiempo ahora mismo para construir
conexiones nuevas con otros países como
por ejemplo china o la india tampoco
pueden enviarlo por barcos porque pues
porque casi todos estos campos de gas
están en la costa ártica y buena suerte'
zarpando un barco de gas natural licuado
en pleno invierno en el océano ártico
dicho de otra forma que sin el dinero
del gas el kremlin no puede seguir
financiando la guerra de ucrania ni eso
ni tampoco sus gastos corrientes y
diréis a los entonces fin del problema
verdad ya putin no va a cortar el gas
asunto resuelto pues no para nada
atentos a esta gráfica
lo que veis aquí es el precio de los
futuros ttf del gas natural neerlandés
podríamos decir que es la referencia que
se utiliza para las negociaciones del
gas ojo porque esto solo es un índice de
referencia es decir que cada país compra
el gas a precios distintos en cualquier
caso si podemos decir que el precio del
gas se ha disparado en todas partes y
que esta gráfica sirve para verlo y qué
significa todo esto pues podemos hacer
dos lecturas primero rusia está más
interesado que nunca en seguir vendiendo
gas a precios prohibitivos nunca habían
hecho tanto dinero como ahora pero
segundo con unos márgenes de beneficio
tan altos rusia puede reducir la
cantidad de gas que vende y a la vez
seguir haciendo unos beneficios nacho
vidal ya nos de esta forma putin mata
dos pájaros de un tiro' por un lado
financia su guerra y por el otro pone
europa contra las cuerdas dónde hay que
firmar así que la pregunta no es si
putin cortará o si no cortará el gas
sino cuánto va a reducir el suministro
20 por ciento cincuenta por ciento
ochenta por ciento pues como os podéis
imaginar nadie puede producir el futuro
pero si podemos hacernos una estimación
como
pues podríamos calcular cuánto dinero
necesita exactamente el kremlin para
cuadrar sus cuentas este año y a partir
de ahí podemos utilizar el precio de los
futuros del gas como referencia cuanto
más caro sea el gas mayor será la
reducción de suministro que podrá ser
rusia evidentemente esto solamente es
una estimación a grosso modo pero ya sé
lo que pensáis alguno venga ya como se
os ve el plumero en visual político de
verdad queréis hacernos creer que putin
es tan malvado de verdad queréis que una
empresa seria como es gazprom va a
romper de la noche a la mañana todos
esos contratos que tienen firmados desde
hace años estos son negocios por favor
una cierto es que tenéis razón gazprom
no va a decir vamos a dejar de vender
gas porque queremos que paséis frías de
invierno
la venganza es mía no estamos hablando
de un mundo de gente seria en estos
ambientes se recurre a excusas queréis
un ejemplo pues os doy un ejemplo
un buen día de este verano de 2022 o
sorpresa las turbinas del gasoducto nord
stream 1 dejaron de funcionar quién mala
suerte o vaya así las turbinas son de
marca siemens que da la casualidad de
que son made in germany pero con las
sanciones a rusia va a ser muy difícil
que alemania un día esas piezas tan
necesarias verdad tal vez haya que
renegociar esas sanciones verdad pues y
es entonces cuando semanas más tarde nos
encontramos con noticias como éste
el gas ruso vuelve a fluir a europa a
través del gasoducto nord stream ahora
bien ese gasoducto solo está operando al
20% de su capacidad al menos en el
momento en el que hacemos este vídeo en
cualquier caso dentro de unos meses
podrían subir este porcentaje como veis
hablamos de una situación muy complicada
para europa y la pregunta es qué se
puede hacer pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Música]
la provisional se para el duro invierno
antes de seguir vamos a dar unos números
para que veáis la magnitud del problema
en el año 2020 la unión europea importo
394 mil millones de metros cúbicos de
gas como se suele medir 394 cms ccm son
billions en inglés de metros cúbicos
pues bien de esta cantidad en 2020 174
bcm vinieron de rusia en 2021 fue algo
menos alrededor de 150 veces y la
pregunta ahora es cómo podemos conseguir
entre 150 y 170 bcm de gas de otros
proveedores que no sean rusia pues bien
tanto la agencia internacional de la
energía como la comisión europea tienen
un plan y la primera parte de este plan
es llenar los depósitos de gas para este
invierno veréis todos los países tienen
depósitos de gas para cubrir los picos
de demanda ahora bien estos depósitos no
dan ni para cubrir una cuarta parte de
la demanda de un invierno y tampoco
creáis que es fácil llenarlos para que
os hagáis una idea en el momento en el
que hacemos este vídeo europa sólo ha
llenado un 66% de sus depósitos de nuevo
cada país los llena a ritmos diferentes
y de nuevo polonia se lleva la medalla
porque es uno de los pocos países que ya
han llenado sus depósitos de gas el
resto están como locos buscando
proveedores en cualquier parte a la vez
que piden que se reduzca el consumo
[Música]
ah
según la agencia internacional de la
energía si este invierno todos los
europeos nos ponemos de acuerdo y
reducimos el termostato en un grado
podríamos llegar a reducir entre 10.000
y 12.000 millones de metros cúbicos de
gas es decir entre 10 y 12 bcm es una
buena idea pues en principio sí pero no
es suficiente 12 bcm son poca cosa si lo
comparamos con las 174 bcm es que
decíamos antes así que siguiente paso
pues buscar proveedores de gas
alternativos vamos a ver qué otros
países venden gas a europa atentos a
esta gráfica
como veis no hay muchas opciones y
recordad que la mayor parte del gas que
llega europa lo hace a través de
gasoductos y no se puede construir un
gasoducto de un día para otro noor agha
por ejemplo ya tienen sus plantas de gas
trabajando a plena potencia y los
gasoductos no pueden dar más gas otro
proveedor interesante podría ser argelia
en los últimos meses la italiana eni ha
negociado un acuerdo con la argelina
sonatrach por cuanto pues por cuatro mil
millones de metros cúbicos de gas es
decir 4 bcm es está bien pero no es
suficiente y tampoco llegarán a tiempo
von der layen por su parte ha viajado a
azerbaiyán para negociar más compras de
gas pero de nuevo no van a llegar a
tiempo construir gasoductos puede llevar
muchísimos años dicho de otra forma
ahora mismo no tenemos tiempo para eso
así que y otras alternativas quedan pues
atentos
[Música]
sálvese quien pueda
imaginado un barco metanero es decir uno
de estos buques enormes que transportan
gas natural liquado está a punto de
llegar a las costas de pakistán desde el
puerto podéis ver cómo se acerca en el
horizonte y sin embargo a pocas millas
de llegar que se da media vuelta y
diréis por qué pues porque en el último
minuto le han hecho una llamada por
teléfono literalmente me han dicho
mucho esto que os acabo de contar puede
parecernos un chiste pero es una
situación real ha ocurrido y no sólo una
sino varias veces en este año 2022 el
mercado de becas se ha convertido en un
auténtico bazar turco pensando así hay
dos formas de comprar gas natural una es
por gasoductos la otra es por barco en
este caso hablamos del famoso gas
natural liquado gml el gasto viene por
gasoductos se negocia a través de
grandes contratos y siempre hay
políticos de por medio por ejemplo el
propio mario draghi cuando todavía era
primer ministro de italia estuvo
presente en la firma del contrato de eni
con sonatrach normalmente hablamos de
contratos por cantidades gigantescas de
dinero ya muy pero que muy largo plazo
algunos pueden extenderse a más de diez
años la ventaja de comprar el gas de
esta manera es que los precios son muy
barato
[Música]
sin embargo el gas natural licuado glp
por sus siglas se puede comprar también
a través de brokers de gas es decir
empresas más pequeñas que compran todo
el gl que cabe en un metanero sin
embargo el gas natural licuado puede ser
hasta 3 veces más caro que el gas que va
por gasoducto así que como europa ya
tenía gas barato a duras penas compraba
barcos sin embargo ahora europa está
desesperada por el gas y tiene muchísimo
más dinero que otros países como por
ejemplo pakistán conclusión pues que
estamos en toda una guerra de precios y
la consigna es da igual lo que te paguen
los demás los europeos de los subimos se
estima que en este año 2022 un país como
bélgica ha incrementado sus compras de
gn el en un seiscientos cincuenta por
ciento y mientras tanto pakistán ha
dejado de comprar nl por un 72% dicho de
otra forma que europa está desviando
buena parte de ese gas que de otro modo
iría para asia y ya dónde viene ese gas
natural liquado pues principalmente de
eeuu pero ojo porque no son el único
país europa está comprando gas a toda
clase de países catar por supuesto
egipto nigeria etcétera la pregunta es
es suficiente con esto para suplir esos
174 mil millones de metros cúbicos de
gas ruso pues francamente es bastante
difícil
y recordad de nuevo dependiendo del año
rusia envía unos 150 y 170 kilómetros
cúbicos de gas natural puede que sea
algo menos pero más o menos tenemos que
llenar un vacío de entre 150 y 170
kilómetros cúbicos de gas natural en
este momento se calcula que europa
podría comprar 50 kilómetros cúbicos
extra de gas natural licuado a otros
proveedores
[Música]
así que ya podéis hacer el cálculo nos
hemos ahorrado unas diez veces bajando
el termostato ahora hemos comprado 50
veces extra a otros proveedores estos
son 60 bcm dicho de otra forma todavía
seguimos necesitando a rusia así que
quien más cosas se pueden hacer para
sustituir el gas ruso pues volverá a
otras fuentes de energía que ya parecían
olvidadas
alemania reactivar a las plantas de
carbón mientras rusia baja el flujo de
gas a alemania se replantea su
desnuclearización por la amenaza de
crisis energética en invierno y de nuevo
la pregunta es de verdad es suficiente
con todo esto para evitar un invierno
duro pues lo cierto es que es muy
difícil predecirlo pero podemos dar tres
escenarios distintos
[Música]
lo mejor de todos es que rusia no cierre
demasiado el grifo vamos a decir que
siguen enviando entre el 80 y el 60 por
ciento del gas en este caso el mayor
problema será la subida salvaje de
precios pero ya está un problema
económico y fin de la cuestión el
escenario medio malo es que rusia cierre
un poco más el gas en este caso los
gobiernos priorizarían a los hogares por
encima de las industrias pero muchas
fábricas tendrían que cerrar y los
checos se quedarían sin su cerveza pero
lo bueno es que no se morirían de frío y
el escenario realmente malo sería que
rusia cerrarse el grifo y solo nos
vendiera un 20% o algo así en este caso
si podríamos vernos en la situación de
racionamiento de gas en las casas es
decir podría darse el caso de que en
algunos países de europa sólo se pudiera
atender la calefacción en determinadas
horas del día y llegados a este punto
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros en
cuál de estos tres escenarios creéis que
vamos a terminar es posible encontrar
nuevos proveedores de gas para el
invierno del año que viene podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios
antes de terminar me gustaría dar las
gracias a adrián dudas de ego de
research adrián es un inversor
especializado en materias primas también
quiero dar las gracias a marcial
gonzález que es un ingeniero
especializado en energía por la
universidad carlos iii de madrid' ambos
me han ayudado con la investigación para
este vídeo así que muchas gracias y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
politics sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos este canal y
dadle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo darle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un saludo y
hasta pronto
[Música]